-Oh, boy.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
[ Light laughter ]
Hold on.
Okay, okay.
Oh, I see what's going on.
Alright.
Marlon, don't do anything.
Marlon, don't do anything weird.
[ Laughter ]
Don't do anything weird!
Marlon, just sit there, please
-I'm protecting you.
You're fine.
-Okay, ready?
Ready? Here we go.
-Person, place, or an animal
A flower?
A sombrero.
[ Laughter ]
Uh, a cactus?
A bow tie.
A hat with a pinwheel thin
on it?
Oh, you're bad at this.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪♪♪
-This game works
exactly like Pictionary,
except the person who's drawin
[Laughs]
will be wearing one of these
virtual-reality headsets
and drawing in 3-D space,
using a program
called Tilt Brush.
We'll be able
to see their point-of-view
up on the big screen upstage
45 seconds per turn.
I'll go first.
You guys
can all take your seats.
There you go there, buddy.
Alright.
[ Light laughter ]
[ Laughing ] Gosh.
-[ Laughs ]
-Wait. So, me and him's
on the same team?
-Yeah.
-Are we guessing?
-No, not yet.
-Okay.
-I'm guessing.
-Yeah, you're gonna guess
when I -- when I draw.
Oh, I got to
pick a number first, sorry
Uh...
Which one?
[ Audience shouting ]
4 is right there.
I guess I'll just do it.
There we go.
-Jimmy, no cheating,
'cause you cheated me last time.
I remember --
I remember that.
-I didn't -- I didn't cheat.
I never cheat.
-You've played this before
-Not here.
It was another game
he cheated me in.
He's good in cheating
all the games he hosts.
-Never -- I don't cheat,
and you've never
played this before with me
so here we go.
This is a thing, okay.
Oh, can I say --
Can I say what it is?
It's a person --
-You can't say.
-I can't?
-Can you say?
-See?
There goes the cheating already.
I'm telling y'all.
[ Laughter ]
-I can say the category.
Yeah,
person, place, or an animal.
That doesn't even help.
-That's all the things.
-That could be everything.
That's everything, almost.
[ Laughter ]
What a bad hint that was, yeah
Person, place, or an animal.
Oh, boy.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
[ Light laughter ]
Hold on.
-Okay, okay.
Oh, I see what's going on.
Alright.
Marlon, don't do anything.
Marlon, don't do anything weird.
[ Laughter ]
Don't do anything weird!
Marlon, just sit there, please
-I'm protecting you.
You're fine.
-Ready? Here we go.
-Person, place, or an animal
A flower?
A sombrero.
[ Laughter ]
Uh, a cactus?
A bow tie.
A hat with a pinwheel thin
on it?
Oh, you're bad at this.
[ Laughter ]
A bumblebee?
Uh, Yoshi.
A butterfly.
Uh...popcorn?
I'm really stretching here
-Jimmy's drawing's so bad,
his parents
wouldn't even hang it up.
[ Laughter ]
This is terrible!
-I'm afraid --
-A potato.
-Wait. I can't --
-Let me help you out -- vomit.
-A butterfly!
A but-- A butterfly's nest
A butterfly net.
[ Buzzer ]
-Oh! Oh!
Tha-- Oh!
That was
the longest drumroll ever.
And I tell you,
the cheating's in.
-I just broke a sweat
playing Pictionary.
[ Laughter ]
-Can I -- Can I guess now?
For points?
-Yes.
-It's a cocoon.
-No.
-That's a good guess, though
-A dragonfly.
-What?!
-Oh, my God.
-You didn't draw a dragonfly
-I didn't?
-No, you drew a butterfly.
Dragonflies have a longer body
and smaller --
-Okay. What was the vomit
that you drew?
-That was the tail -- the tail
-Of a what?
-Of the dragonfly.
[ Laughter ]
-What dragon does this?
-You're up next, Marlon.
Here.
-Oh, me. Okay, cool.
-Pick a number first, and then
I can help you with that.
-This gonna mess my naps.
It's your show.
You don't want to do...?
[ Light laughter ]
-Wait. No.
First, wait, stop.
First,
I have to give you a thing
Wait. Hold --
-I can see. I see.
-No, you have to take --
-I see it.
-No, no, I know you see this
You have to look
at the clue first.
The clue.
-Oh, okay. There we go.
-Alright, which clue --
Which one should he do?
[ Audience shouting ]
-84!
[ Laughs ]
-This is like
"The Price Is Right."
-This like
"The Price Is Right" -- 1, 4
Number 3! 7!
Alright!
I'm gonna go with 5! 5!
-Gonna go with 5, alright.
-5!
-Okay, 5.
I don't want to see it.
Tariq guesses this.
-Whoever picked 5,
please see me afterward.
We fighting.
[ Laughter ]
-Can I say what it is?
Ready?
-Here we go.
[ Clock ticking ]
-A cat, a kitten.
-A kitten.
"Tom and Jerry."
Um...
A puppy? A dog?
A mouse?
It's a cat, right?
Is it a rock--
Is it horse, a rocking horse
What is that?
-Use the space!
This is fantastic, by the way.
-This man is --
You can't get this?!
This is Picasso right here
[ Laughter and applause ]
-The devil!
Hell! The devil!
-That's one.
-Dante's "Inferno."
-What?!
-That's one.
-"Devil in a Blue Dress."
-You got that part, right?
Now, you got to get this part.
-Which part?
-Let me do it again.
Alright, come from over here
Ready?
[ Buzzer ]
-You didn't give me
no drumroll!
You didn't even
give me a drumroll!
[ Laughter ]
-Not everyone gets a drumroll!
-Hey, man!
Last time I checked,
you black, too!
You have to give the drumroll!
-Hey, come on!
It's not a racial thing!
It's not a racist thing.
It's gonna be alright.
-Talk to your man.
[ Laughter ]
And it's a deviled egg.
Look, I -- I know it's foo
we don't eat, man, but come on
[ Laughter and applause ]
We've been to white barbecues.
They like deviled eggs, man!
-White barbecues.
Oh, my gosh.
Deviled egg.
I didn't know --
It looked like a dragonfly
that last one.
Alright, Brie, you're up.
-Oh, I'm up?
-Yeah.
-Ooh, the pressure's on.
You guys were really good.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, wait.
I got to pick something.
What's my number, y'all?
[ Audience shouting ]
7.
-And then you pick it up
with this.
-Oh, you've
got to be kidding me.
-Wait. Is it hard?
Is it hard?
-It's hard.
-Yes!
-Okay.
This is a movie.
-Yep.
-Ready?
-Yes.
[ Clock ticking ]
"Jurassic Park."
[ Laughter ]
Uh, uh..."Jaws"!
"Sharknado 5"!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Fanfare ]
-That was good!
♪♪♪♪
-I mean, come on!
-That was good.
-That was good, right?
"Sharknado 5."
-Where did you see a shark?!
[ Laughter ]
-You didn't see a fin?
-That looked like a foot
with some glass in it.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Guys, Tariq, it is your turn.
This is the final round.
It's gonna be a showdown.
If Marlon guesses
the clue first,
then you guys win.
If Brie or I guess it,
then we win.
Okay?
There you go.
-You got to guess --
How you guess when I start
-It's the last round.
[ Audience shouting ]
-So, we can guess on this?
-Yeah, we guess it, too.
-we get to guess it?
-Yeah, if we guess it first,
we win.
[ Shouting continues ]
-Okay.
-You guess it.
-It's easy.
It's a phrase.
-It's a phrase.
Easy.
-Yeah.
-Alright.
-It's a phrase.
Here we go.
-You want to move out the wa
a little bit, brother.
Thank you.
[ Light laughter ]
[ Clock ticking ]
-You got to pull the trigger
on the thing.
-Oh, okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Camel.
-Camel hump!
Wave.
Dinosaur.
Camel.
-A phrase.
A dino-saur.
-Old as a dinosaur.
-A bronto --
Dinosaur.
-Check --
Check your dinosaur grass.
Checks and balances.
Hump --
-Hump -- Hump Day.
[ Fanfare ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Who got that?
Hump Day, right?
-Yeah.
I said it!
-Did you get that?
-I said "Hump Day"!
-What'd he say?
-Hump Day!
Wednesday. That's today.
-See, you busy talking trash
-I said "hump grass."
-Hump grass?
What is that?
-Time-out!
You got 62 Roots!
You give me the dumbest on
out of all of them!
[ Laughter, audience groans
You got 62 of them!
-What is he doing?
No, no, no!
My thanks to Brie Larson,
Marlon Wayans, Tariq Trotter
This game works
exactly like Pictionary,
except the person who is drawing
will be wearing one of these
virtual reality headsets.
Okay?
And you're drawing
in a 3-D space
using a program
called Tilt Brush.
You just pull the trigger
on this and draw with it.
We'll be able to see
their point of view
on the big screen upstage.
45 seconds per turn.
I'll go first.
-Look at T's face.
-I know.
Get ready.
No, you're gonna dig it.
-I know there's
some kind of trick to this
-No, no, no, no, no.
You -- here, have a seat.
-I'm very excited.
-Put this thing on your head
Don't worry about.
-I'm telling you,
you'll dig this.
Alright, I'll go first.
Here we go.
The good thing is, you jus
look cool playing it.
-Yeah.
-Alright, here we go.
What number should I chose
[ Audience shouting ]
-Wow. Okay.
That was very organized.
5. I heard 5 first.
-42.
-Here we go.
Buddy, we got this.
-I got this.
I'm with you.
-Okay, okay, okay.
[ Laughter ]
I don't know, man. Oh, my gosh
-What is it?
-Here go. Ready?
It's an object.
-It's an object.
-Okay.
-There you go.
-Okay, alright.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Wow. I am having --
I am having a real hard time
Is it Jesus?
-No, it's not Jesus.
No eyeballs.
-[ Laughs ] Oh, yeah.
Oh, my goodness.
I'm feeling --
Bart Simpson?
[ Light laughter ]
It's -- It's --
-I don't --
Oh, oh.
-Oh, oh. Okay.
And --
It's a Peanut.
It's Charlie Brown.
Charlie Brown -- Schroeder
The -- P.O. --
The thing.
The Great Pumpkin.
Uh, the -- the -- Oh, Snoopy
[ Buzzer ]
[ Sad trombone ]
I got so close, didn't I?
-Gosh.
I didn't know how to do it
Nutcracker.
-What?
-I know it's bad.
Alright.
Just look.
I'm just showing you.
Alright. Here we go.
Ice-T, you're up next.
-I got to draw?
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now you saw how to do it.
Now you see what you got to do
Alright, you walk around.
It's 3-D.
It's a 3-D world
you can walk around.
-Alright.
-You'll be fine.
-Alright, now what --
-You hold down.
-Alright. Now I pick this --
I got to -- right?
-And now, what number
do you guys want?
[ Audience shouting ]
9? I heard 7.
Up to you.
Sorry about that.
-We got this.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
This is an action.
-Here we go.
-Okay.
-He is really serious.
[ Light laughter ]
[ Laughter ]
-Sailing.
Boating.
Traveling the islands.
Yachting.
Traveling.
[ Laughter ]
Finding treasure!
-Here's where it gets --
Here's where it gets fun.
[ Laughter ]
-Scuba diving.
[ Bell dings ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hey!
-I had to make the water
first, so you knew.
-You guys --
-That's what 20 years
will get you.
-That's chemistry --
That's chemistry right there
-I think we should become
detectives now.
-Come on, buddy. We can do it.
Yeah, we'll be detectives
together.
-Let's do this.
We could do it if we --
-Catch us now.
-So proud of you!
-Nutcracker was a tough on
to start with. Alright?
-Alright.
-Macaulay, I'm a better --
-I should have known, though
-I'm a better guesser.
I'm a better --
-Which number?
Just kidding.
I'm picking 8.
It doesn't matter.
-"I'm picking 8."
-Hmm. Okay.
-We got this, buddy.
We got this. I'm telling you
-Okay. Alright.
Hold on.
I'm in a virtual reality
situation.
Alright.
-You didn't give a clue.
-Oh, yeah -- it's a --
it's a place.
-I just helped you.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I appreciate -- Thank you buddy.
I appreciate it.
-You know what?
Thanks, Ice-T.
-Thank you.
Yeah. That's good.
Yeah.
-Alright. Let's do this.
-People don't say that enough.
-I know. Right?
Thank you.
-Okay.
-Oh.
-Oh, my God.
It's a beautiful globe.
[ Laughter ]
The top of the -- North Pole
-Yeah.
[ Bell dings ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow! Wow!
-That's right! That is right
-Yeah!
-Ugh!
In your face!
-That is -- Okay.
-North Pole!
-First of all, you're
a really good artist.
-You didn't even need a clue
-Oh, thank you.
-I could have never done that.
That was awesome.
-That was great virtual art.
-Virtual artist. Wow.
You're a good artist.
-Should I take matters int
my own hands here?
-Oh, yeah.
Should I help you?
-Oh, yeah. Help her.
-Do you want me to help?
-How do I know what number
-Oh, yeah.
What number do you guys want
[ Audience shouting ]
They want 7.
That's the clue.
-Okay. It's a movie.
-Alright.
You can tell that to us.
Okay, yeah.
-I don't like this number.
-Ice, Ice, Ice. It's good.
[ Laughter ]
Okay, ready?
-Yeah.
-Alright.
-Whoa.
[ Light laughter ]
What?!
[ Laughter ]
-"Jaws."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-So pretend it says
that at the end --
-You can't write --
-You can't write words.
-Oh. Oh, sorry.
Okay, ready?
-That's fine.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, okay.
-It's a fish.
-No.
-It's a bird?
-Scuba diver!
-Look, look, look.
-Scuba diving again.
[ Laughter ]
[ Buzzer, sad trombone ]
-What the...
-Ice!
-That's a plane?
-Yes!
-Uh, um, "Airplane"?
-No!
Show it again.
[ Laughing] Show it again.
-You won't get it.
-That's really bad.
-"Snakes on a Plane."
-Nobody saw that movie!
-Oh, come on.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Not the point, not the point
That's not the point
of the game.
-That's not the point.
-Not the point of the game
It's time for the final round.
-Nobody saw "The Nutcracker"
either.
-That was Sam's worst movie.
-It is going to be --
Alright. Here we go.
I'm gonna -- What -- Which one
[ Audience shouting ]
I'll do this one.
-Alright.
-Oh, gosh.
-You guys are savages.
-Well...
No one's gonna get this one.
So, here we go.
[ Laughter ]
-What is it?
What is it?
-Oh, it is a -- it's a song.
It's a -- it's a --
it's a book. It's a cartoon.
-What?
-It's a song, a book,
and a cartoon?
-Yeah.
No one's gonna get it.
Alright, ready?
-Okay.
-A song, a book, and a cartoon
[ Light laughter ]
-Look at that. Oh, hey.
-Felix! [ Laughs ]
-Uh, ugh.
-Wow, it's very good.
[ Light laughter ]
-Oh!
-Uh, Scooby-Doo!
It so looks like Scooby-Doo.
-Ooh.
I'm really having a hard tim
with this one.
-He's a cat man!
-It's a cat? Is it a...
-It's a dinosaur.
-It's an animal.
-Cat-Man.
-Cat.
Dinosaur.
It's a dinosaur or a cat?
-Barney?
-Stop saying ""cat.
-[Laughing] Barney.
-Ain't he a dinosaur?
-Wait a minute.
What is that?
-Snoop Dogg!
-Snoop Dogg?
It's a rapper.
Snoopy. Snoopy?
-Snoop Lion.
-Oh, my God.
[ Buzzer ]
[ Sad trombone ]
-It's officially --
We're gonna officially end this.
That was
"Puff the Magic Dragon."
-Oh!
-Wow.
-We're officially gonna
end on a tie.
We're gonna have to have
a rematch.
My thanks to Ice-T,
Mariska Hargitay,
Macaulay Culkin.